this is a very interesting uh
legal story in terms of the precedent
that it could set and we knew it was
only a matter of time until this was
happening
and it's happening now the lawyer of one
of the trump rioters who has been
charged for his role in the january 6
riots
which were of course inspired by donald
trump is using
so-called fox mania
and fox itis as a defense
for his client the 27 year old uh
is charged uh anthony antonio is his
name 27 year old anthony antonio
is charged with unlawful and violent
entry
of the capital police obstruction and
destruction of government property
according to an arrest warrant the
lawyer for anthony antonio whose name is
joseph hurley
claims that fox news is to blame
for the alleged actions of his client
his attorney said as reported by
huffpost
quote fox itis he became
hooked with what i call foxmania
antonio quote started believing
what was being fed to him says his
lawyer
and there is a very dangerous
in never-ending circle of liability here
to consider
because here you have a lawyer blaming
fox news
and fox news in the past has used
as a legal defense that at least their
opinion programming
is merely entertainment it's not news
none of it should be taken literally
and so is anyone to blame for this guy's
actions i know that as the party of
personal responsibility you would think
the right would be saying well
the individual is to blame but is anyone
actually going to be held accountable
and certainly
i mean listen what the lawyer is saying
isn't crazy
there is much reason to think that fox
news and newsmax and oan
they are partially to blame for inciting
and ginning these people up
for months with claims of election fraud
but there is also plenty of reason to
think that antonio himself
has to be responsible here we have in
the exhibits
in this particular case video footage
that shows
the defendant wearing a bulletproof vest
with a patch representing the three
percenters which is an
extremist anti-government group um he
is seen shouting at officers in the
crowd uh
on video saying you want war we got war
1776 all over again antonio was later
captured on video
being handed a riot shield which seemed
to have been stolen
law enforcement property he eventually
used that shield
to push his way to the front of the
crowd and then he was seen squirting
water on a police officer who was then
dragged into the crowd throwing a bottle
in the direction of police officers
it can't all be fox news's fault right
although i do agree
that the role of media in getting people
fired up
by airing endless conspiracies even if
as they say
our guests were saying those things we
weren't saying those things
um there's no doubt that that that's an
aspect of this
but fox made me do it that's it
uh who didn't see this defense coming
though
um we with it it was obviously
going to be fingers pointing at other
people even oh he just got caught up in
the group he got kind of pushed in by
the mob
into the into the capitol building now
of course
they could also argue in court
that actually it was trump as much as
fox news
is to blame trump is to blame call it
you know instead of foxitis
trumporia or something like that but
that seems less
likely to play as well as maybe this
could and i don't know if this will work
we're going to have to follow the case
is there a treatment for trump area
is there an antidote to foxitis or
foxmania
so we're going to follow the case we'll
see what impact it has
on the court because the precedent
setting power of this could be
significant and i would be
if this works at all i expect to see
many of the defense lawyers for those
charged in the january 6 trump riots
uh to try to use exactly this defense
let me know if you think it will work
but also you know not
maybe not from a legal standpoint but
obviously the rioters deserve the lion's
share of the consequences for what they
did
but how do you think blame should go
around
between merely the rioters themselves
who did the thing
donald trump and right-wing media
that ginned this stuff up for months how
would you split it up
60 20 20 80 10 10
i don't know let me know what you think
and we'll have a follow-up about it